[Música]
buenos días familia cómo estamos qué
lindas charlas que hemos escuchado hoy y
aquí para empezar me gustaría que
lleváramos los ojos y nos imaginemos una
deliciosa cerveza
a dónde están
en la playa
en un bar rodeado de amigos
o tal vez están sentados alrededor del
fuego
y de que están tomando
una botella
de un vaso helado
o quizás de una jícara o calabacín
aunque muchas veces pensamos en la
cerveza como una bebida rubio pálida con
una gran espuma que además
necesariamente se tiene que tomar en la
disímil
la cerveza ha tenido muchísimas
variaciones a lo largo de la humanidad
y aquí mismo en costa rica de hecho
tenemos una cerveza ancestral que tiene
más de 3000 años con nosotros y que se
hace no de cebada sino de maíz otro
grano tradicional para fermentación
llevamos más de 13.000 años fermentando
cervezas en el mundo así una bebida que
nos ha acompañado en la civilización y
en la humanidad
entonces yo me pregunto
como podemos
entender el rol que ha tenido la cerveza
y por qué es la bebida más tomada
en la historia después del agua y el té
y aún la bebida alcohólica más tomada en
el mundo
yo empecé este
interés por la cerveza ancestral a
través de mi desarrollo como cervecera y
en ese momento pensaba que estas
cervezas espirituales habían estado
perdidas hace miles de años en las
antiguas civilizaciones de sumeria y
egipto
y no fue hasta un momento que escuché
una historia de nuestra región
latinoamericana como una región
cervecera tradicional que me agarró
mucho interés por este tema regional
contaba steven benner que es un
herbalist a estadounidense que ellos se
fueron en busca de la mejor cerveza del
mundo que estaba en el amazonas
y entonces sobrevolaron este denso
bosque de la amazona buscando campos de
yuca y de maíz
tratando de encontrar una comunidad
que hiciera cerveza de forma ancestral
finalmente la encontraron se devolvieron
y caminaron a pie por varios días hasta
finalmente encontrar con la aldea a
donde pidieron hablar con la mejor
cervecera de la comunidad y los llevaron
a donde una señora
viejita
que les dio lo que aún dijeron que era
la mejor cerveza que habían probado en
la vida
aún mejor o igual que muchas de las
cervezas de monasterio belgas que tan
afamadas son entre nosotros cerveceros
y a mí esa historia me quedo así como a
flor de piel
y me quedo la cabeza hasta que me hizo
regresar me aquí a costa rica y tratar
de ver si efectivamente
existía una cerveza ancestral aún en
este país
y muy pronto
me vi
tratando de entender en que lo que era
me había metido que me había llevado a
estar metida en un rancho escuchando los
ecos de los cantos del jaguar
metida en el denso denso bosque de la
montaña una montaña aquí
que se considera sagrada en costa rica
que se llama talamanca donde está la
reserva indígena bribri
y ahí conocí la cerveza ancestral por
primera vez
esta cerveza la producía
un señor que se llama don marcelino
figueroa
y de ahí no sólo con él sino con otros
maestros y maestras también
aprendí que la cerveza se tenía que
producir y tomar con intención
fue tomando cerveza de maíz en calabazas
en jícaras o calabacines en ceremonia
que aprendí que si tomábamos con
intención y pedíamos permiso a la
cerveza no íbamos a sentir malestar ni
dificultad con esta bebida
cosa que no entendieron un grupo de
muchachos que una vez
llegaron a nuestra finca y se robaron un
litro de chicha de cerveza de maíz y ni
siquiera lograron salir de la finca
porque con el primer sorbo quedaron como
decimos aquí en el país sentado de culo
y es porque no tomaron con intención
y aunque este tipo de ideas pensar
sentirse como un poco mágicas o irreales
la realidad es que siempre hemos
fermentado cerveza con intención
y siempre hemos tomado con
espiritualidad
toda civilización humana
tiene una cerveza ancestral
desde sumeria con sus cervezas de cebada
hasta áfrica con sus cervezas de sorgo
mesoamérica con sus cervezas de maíz
o inclusive hacia con sus cervezas de
arroz toda civilización creó una cultura
alrededor del crecimiento de estos
granos que se crecían no sólo para hacer
diferentes comidas sino principalmente
para ser bebidas alcohólicas fermentadas
que eran la base de la nutrición de las
comunidades y estas bebidas
principalmente las hacían mujeres
de forma ceremonial como la fermentación
se consideraba un acto de magia era como
algo que no entendíamos en ese momento
no conocíamos las levaduras
como tal cual todas al fermentar sólo se
fermentadas y había conexión con los
dioses
y las cerveceras llevaban rituales
bailes cantos muy importantes para poder
desarrollar esta conexión no sólo
desarrollamos la espiritualidad en
conexión con cerveza sino que también
parte de nuestra sociedad viene de la
cerveza yo no sé si aquí hay contadores
en el público que saben una de las
primeras facturas de la humanidad fue la
factura de a lulú por un litro de
cerveza
o si hay algún abogado que en el público
que es estoy seguro saben del código
hammurabi que es el primer código legal
de la humanidad pero que en ese código
dice que toda persona en babilonia tiene
el derecho universal de recibir una
oración diaria de cerveza no importa su
clase social o quien sea
entonces eso no lo podemos imaginar
ahorita
porque en la constitución de costa rica
ya no vemos la cerveza como algo sagrado
ni en nuestros corazones tampoco hemos
olvidado
así que yo me pregunto cómo podemos
retomar la cerveza desde la conciencia
desde la espiritualidad y no desde el
abuso porque como productores de cerveza
no estamos haciendo una droga para la
sociedad
estamos rezando a las madres estamos
rezando a los granos que nos han
acompañado en toda civilización humana
y en un momento a donde estamos
produciendo
e ingiriendo
productos ultra procesados que están
dañando a nuestros cuerpos
y que hay muchas personas tratando de
pensar cómo podemos crecer comida
diferente cómo podemos producir comida
diferente que vuelva a conectar con el
recuerdo que tenemos de cómo vivir en
balance con la tierra con nuestro
espíritu cuando nuestros estómagos
mi ámbito a la cerveza como tal vez para
muchos hay ámbitos diferentes para mí lo
importante es que retomemos nuestro
concepto de cerveza
así que yo les doy una invitación a los
productores de cerveza a siempre
producir con intención y a los
consumidores que la próxima vez que se
vayan a tomar una cerveza
piensen un poquito en su origen y en su
importancia en nuestro desarrollo en la
civilización
y tomen con conciencia
valor en la cerveza no solo por su
alcohol por su contenido alcohólico
sino principalmente por su contenido
espiritual
les deseo un gran camino explorando la
cerveza
que recen a los dioses que tomen con
conciencia
salud
[Aplausos]
[Música]